gut dass du da bist setzte ich mach's
dir gemütlich hol dir deine kopfhörer
sitzen jetzt ein bisschen unsere gehirne
der sonne
weil ich gerade fragt warum ich flüstere
dann habt ihr wahrscheinlich noch nicht
von menschen sich diese asse mal videos
gerne an weil sie dabei ein wohlig
kitzeln des fast schon elektrisierendes
gefühlte spüren ließ dem kopf im schädel
nackenbereich
das kann dann runter gehen bis zu den
schultern oder bis in den rücken und die
arme
siebert sein das leise geräusche solche
körperlichen sinne auslösen
das werden wir uns sollte
wissenschaftlich anschauen wann wir es
mal damit an die den menschen überhaupt
erst erleben
dazu gibt es leider noch keine
umfassenden studien ja bisher auch nur
eine kleine umfrage befunden 91 menschen
befragen und merkte an dass sie es immer
leben füllen können wir können ihr zu
der aufklärung beitragen stimmt die
roben habe wie es bei euch aussieht und
ich bin mir sicher wir kriegen wir als
91 leute
zusammen ich selbst spüre überhaupt
nichts wenn ich solche es immer video
sehe für mich ist das alles eine theorie
deswegen freue ich mich dieses mal
besonders auf eure kommentare und bitte
falls ihr sma erleben könnt spüren
können dann schreib mir doch mal ein
bisschen ausführlicher wie sich das
anfühlt youtube wurde es immer so
bekannt dass irgendwann sogar die
wissenschaft darauf aufmerksam wurde ich
meine
schau dich mal diese wissenschaftliche
führung an
jetzt ungelogen eine tabelle mit youtube
einen drin ich meine teil ist das denn
bitte
dieses thema ist übrigens eines der
wenigen die das phänomen
wissenschaftlich untersuchen und nicht
nur beschreiben
dazu haben sie einige hundert leute
befragt die nach eigenen angaben sma
haben den fragebogen der studie in
venedig euch unten
den könnt ihr euch mal anschauen war es
euch dafür interessiert laut dieser
studie sind dann folgendes die
hauptträger die es immer auslösen nummer
eins christian nummern zwei persönliche
aufmerksamkeit oft ihr das erste
erlebnis besonders gut wenn es mit
rollenspielen gepaart ist
sehr beliebt sind ein friseurbesuch oder
auch seltsamerweise ein arztbesuch
nummer drei knackige töne
deshalb werden auch die eine idee aus
als gegenstände benutzt oder ist das gut
ich weiß ich weiß nicht
und interessanterweise erleben menschen
diesen gefühlen nicht nur durch
geräusche sondern zum beispiel auch
durch visuelle reize ganz oben mit dabei
ist niemand anderen dabei zu beobachten
wie er unter sie etwas malte oder
zeichnet
und auch haptische reize drin es immer
angeblich auslösen und darunter haare
anfassen
sowohl die haare von jemand anderem als
auch in die eigenen haare oder auch
jemand anderen mieter oder nagellack
aufgetragen fragen alle ist maler da
draußen
was sind eure lieblings trigger und den
ihr das ist jetzt ein gutes im video
und da könnte ich irgendetwas besser
machen nicht ganz nicht beurteilen weil
ich spüre es wie gesagt nicht die studie
untersuchte außerdem sma
depressionen helfen könnte vor
teilnehmern mit depressionen gab es
einen deutlichen stimmungsumschwung beim
schauen solcher es immer videos und
diese erhöhte stimmung die hielt auch
ein paar stunden danach noch an und
interessantes aus
je stärker die depression desto größer
der stimmungs sprung fast alle gaben an
dass die krise war sehr entspannend
finden
viele gaben an dass sie es immer gerne
zum einschlafen schauen könnt ihr mal
ausprobieren mit diesem video
das ganze ist vor allem für mich ist es
eher unwahrscheinlich dass es immer eine
art sexueller fetischist was manche
vermuten
aber das empfinden die wenigsten so so
interessant diese studio ist die daten
nun fragebögen und auf eigenen aussagen
der teilnehmer
wenn man das jetzt sind sorgfältig
untersuchen wollte muss man ein paar
schritte weiter gehen japaner studie
gefunden wo jens gemacht
die leute die er ist immer leben wo wir
wirklich mit leuten die mir wirklich
viel praktische konsequenzen ziehen
vor allem war diese studie unglaublich
klein
es war nur jeweils elf teilnehmer pro
gruppe man vermutet aber dass die
sensorischen hirnregionen also die teile
des gehirns die füße in spanien
zuständig sind
dass die bei sma land generell stärker
benutzt sind ist die sie wirklich dass
es ein ähnlich abgefahrenes phänomen wo
menschen zum beispiel töne sehen also wo
menschen mit verschiedenen tönen zum
beispiel verschiedene farben verbinden
abgesehen davon dass sma einsetzenden
and rent ist könnte es ernst dann bot in
der alle haben als therapeutisches
mittel gegen depressionen vielleicht
auch gegen angstzustände
aber dafür muss es immer erst mal ein
bisschen näher untersucht werden wie
gesagt würde mich sehr interessieren was
zum teufel mit euch los und in der end
grad
herzlich willkommen bei einem
friseurtermin wie macht man das jetzt
eigentlich müsste ich so machen oder
aber dann hört man es nicht so gut
ok schneide jetzt deine haare da
währenddessen und gar nicht ihr ding ist
gossip it's my life wurde für den grimme
online award nominiert
und es gibt ein publikumspreis weißt du
mich unterstützen willst als dankeschön
dafür dass ich dir die haare schneiden
dann kannst du in den weg in der video
beschreibung schauen ich gebe dir als
gegenleistung und wochen war extra ein
close-up scherenschnitte ist es gut